SARAH, WE ARE GOING TO GET BACK
TO YOU.
BUT, FIRST, WAY AND ON MORE OF
THIS BREAKING NEWS.
WE WILL HAVE A BIG PART TO PLAY
IN THIS AND IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE.
SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, I THINK WE ARE
BEGINNING NOW THE PAINTING THE
PICTURES FILLING IN WITH THE
CORROBORATION, NOT THAT WE
NEEDED IT, WE HAVEN'T BEEN LONG
HERE.
WE'VE BEEN WAY OUT OF THE CAR OF
THE TO GREAT REPORTING OF PEOPLE
WE HAVE ON THE SHOW TONIGHT AND
MANY OTHERS THAT ARE A MENTION.
BUT THESE ARE QUESTIONS NOW THAT
YOUR COMMITTEE WILL BE DEALING
WITH.
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
TAKE THIS NEWS AND TELL US HOW
YOU WOULD INTERPRET IT.
>> THIS IS THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
I KNOW PERSONALLY THERE'S A LOT
MORE OUT THERE AND THE WORD THAT
KEEPS COMING UP HIS BIAS.
THE PEOPLE INVESTIGATING CLINTON
WANTED HER TO WIN AND TRYING TO
LOSE.
THE PEOPLE WHO STARTED THE
INVESTIGATION AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTED HIM TO
LOSE AND HEARD A WIN.
THE CHIEF SOURCE OF THE FAISAL
WARRANTS WAS MR. STEELE WHO
HATED TRUMP'S GOT SO THERE A
COMMON THEME HERE THAT THE
INVESTIGATION OF TRUMP WAS VERY
BIASED AND THE FACT THAT
McCABE HAS SUED IS VERY
INTERESTING TO ME.
IT GIVES ME A CHANCE AS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE TO
LOOK INTO WHETHER OR NOT THE FBI
ACTED INAPPROPRIATELY TOWARDS
MR. McCABE OR WAS IT HIS FAULT
THAT HE GOT FIRED?
I WOULD LOOK INTO THAT.
>> Sean: IS IT FAIR FOR ME TO
SAY THE FOLLOWING --
ALL OF THIS CAST OF CHARACTERS,
THE MAJORITY OF THEM WERE
INVOLVED IN A RIGGED
INVESTIGATION WHERE THE EVIDENCE
INTO VIOLATING THE ESPIONAGE ACT
WAS OVERWHELMING AND
INCONTROVERTIBLE AND NOT BEING
THE UNDERLYING CRIME, THE
SUBPOENAED EMAILS THAT WERE
DELETED AND ACID WASHED AND
BEATEN UP WITH HAMMERS,
ET CETERA, THAT WOULD BE A
SLAM-DUNK OBSTRUCTION CASE.
IS IT FAIR TO SAY THE RUSSIAN
LINE IS THAT HILLARY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR AND EVEN
STEELE DIDN'T STAND BY WHAT IS,
IN FACT, USED AS THE BASIS OF A
PHIS APPLICATION ON FOUR
SEPARATE APPLICATIONS, DENYING
THE CIVIL LIBERTIES OF
CARTER PAGE AND ALSO, SPYING
INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, TRUMP
TRANSITION, AND LATER, TRUMP
PRESIDENCY, AND IS IT FAIR TO
SAY THAT IT IS LOOKING MORE
LIKELY EVERY DAY THAT THE TOP
OFFICIALS IN OUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY OF USED THEIR POWER
AND TO CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN LAW,
OUTSOURCED THINGS THAT WOULD BE
ILLEGAL FOR THEM TO DO, SPYING
ON AMERICANS, AND USING SPIES
LIKE JOSEPH SMITH'S FLUID AND
STUFF ON HELPER, AND ALLIES OF
OURS, AGAIN, ON A SEPARATE
TRACK, TO AGAIN SPY ON THE TRUMP
TRANSITION, TRUMP PRESIDENCY?
IS THAT A FAIR CONCLUSION AT
THIS POINT WHERE WE ARE GOING?
>> YEAH, I THINK IT'S A PRETTY
GOOD OVERVIEW.
THE QUESTION FOR ME IS, IS THE
REASON HILLARY CLINTON WASN'T
PROSECUTED IS BECAUSE THEY
WANTED HER TO BE PRESIDENT AND
THEY KNEW THAT IF THEY BOUGHT A
CASE AGAINST RAY CLINTON FOR
COMPROMISING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, SHE WILL LOSE THE
ELECTION AND THEY DIDN'T WANT
HER TO LOSE?
I THINK THE INSURANCE POLICY IS
WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE.
GETTING INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,